you're in a second on this episode is a
true entrepreneur will be doing phone
calls shortly I hope everybody's super
awesome and hope everybody had a great
weekend hope you watch the cartoon
little bee if you have not it is
absolutely South Park consistency more
like 38 year olds like you I'm watching
this so that was really fun over the
weekend and that's it huh what do you
got cutie was cool cool anybody else do
anything interesting what else what else
is interesting we have the speaker thing
that's a night tonight 9:00 p.m. Eastern
6:00 Pacific on network yes all right
I'm sure there's some right hooks on
like in my stories or yeah do we have
some swipe ups in my stories where
that'll happen tonight
I'm checking so if you don't know
sneakers which are all back here as you
can see Network which is incredible app
that we worked with
there's the stories ok come back you
know what's really fun about this is we
finally figured out global shipping so
Italy Japan Peru Brazil wherever you
want Canada finally which you can Canada
always like Switzerland and anywhere
else in the world you can order the
sneakers finally tonight so check out
the stories if you want to pick up a
pair I think there's a huge arbitrage
for all the people that buy the pairs
like in places that are not you have a
high tops are getting my shows I think
we played a right you want white high
top black low top I think I know you
wanted them there's one pair
yeah we were gonna I had to decide
between low top high top black/white so
we made all four three thirteen three
thirteen give me one second and great
everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 313 of the askgaryvee
show and i'm excited because the amazing
woman that I'm about to introduce all of
you to is a true bread entrepreneur in
the way that I like to call it I'm just
been so impressed about her career and
I'm gonna let her introduce herself she
also brought tequila which we'll have to
ask her what that's all about but I'm
excited about that
and that's the show so Marcy why don't
you say hello to the vaynernation and
tell everybody a little bit about who
you are when you were zero I started
when I was zero thank you for that that
was Rebecca that was charming right
quick yeah good like that I'm swab boys
charisma go ahead mazing Harry it's
reeking of charisma go ahead in your
sack in 1996 and then sold it to LVMH in
1999 and then sold it again to the
Starwood Hotel Group in 2004 and then I
started a business called soap & Glory
which I sought to boots
Alliance Walgreens yes that's the big UK
retailer yes yes and then I started a
footwear brand called fit flock in 2007
globally so you can still have it and
then started a small ecological brand
called super duper which is only sold in
the UK at the moment but it's about
doing everything right with recycled
plastic and ecological formulas and then
I came up with the idea for the big
whopper the big one which is called
beauty pie beauty pie is a disruptive
buyer's club for lovers of luxury
Cosmetics break that down for me so real
quick as we recap 5 meaningful
businesses that you've launched so far
and and what did you learn with bliss
bliss is obviously a brand I know
extremely well did extremely well here
on the East Coast and all over the world
but I hit my radar as which which
catches my attention what did you learn
in that first what were you doing before
that in 96 let's face it first well in
92 I started doing facials okay and then
I did facials on my own in a room for a
couple of years and then opened and
would you do that when we're we're Soho
prints and Broadway no prints and gosh
was so long ago
Princeton Lafayette bringing Lafayette
spring in Lafayette so in the university
yeah yeah and you were born where I was
born in Canada in Canada what part look
Saskatchewan Canada no kidding 200
people and Meeker now mm and you yeah he
wanted to be in New York one day no in
fact no but I was really bored in Canada
and my sister was a model and she came
to New York when she was probably 18 and
so I was 13 or so and one summer I came
to visit her and then I knew I wanted to
come to New York really yeah there was
so much incredible pumping energy right
and all you needed was piece of pizza
and somewhere to sleep so I knew I
wanted to come back when I finished high
school cool yeah I did well I got
accepted to Columbia and then why then
my payment issues yep yeah kind of fell
through so I ended up moving here but
not having enough money to go to school
habituation understood so I worked as a
personal trainer I was your sister still
here she was at the time yes
yeah so I I was at when she just dropped
the bodybuilder part your eyes lit up
yeah so yeah well just like just cool
like you're not from the bagi really
absolute steal you were hardcore yeah I
was a champion bodybuilder that's about
17 it's amazing are you gonna ask me how
much I get a bench press no but I want
you to share it was quite a lot how much
like 180 it's real it wasn't bad for you
no burn girl sure yeah way more than
Andy can do right he went through the
draft yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't
always need also technique is real as
somebody who like honestly as somebody
like started like only lifting like four
years ago technique is everything I was
doing all like up here anyway so was
your sister please I'm looking forward
to it so your sister was living here
when you she was living here and crash
with her
that was fun you know horrible ah you
know well let's just say I evolved
understood yeah and it's a family thing
I understand you can live together yes
got it I evolved yes you got a job as a
personal trainer when I was about I
guess I was 18 working at this gym
called better bodies which was on I
think 19th between Broadway and
something and everybody worked out there
so Jean Claude went down worked out
there and glass Portuguese we've
subsequently married yes so marry today
do they meet there I don't know they
keep cue gone and then you know there
was a lot of sort of the glitterati of
the time sure that the film producers
and the directors and all the cool you
ever whoever was whoever that was that I
saw
yep yeah and so I went there and was
working out and everyone approached me
to be their personal trainer so I ended
up getting a job being a personal
trainer and then trying to save money so
I could go back to university which I
came here for in the first place and is
that what happened um well I started
taking classes at NYU part-time yep but
then it was very hard to juggle the
personal training schedule and I used to
fall asleep in economics right so I kind
of and you know it was very very
expensive and we were taught at the time
by grad students who weren't necessarily
english-speaking which was difficult in
calculus so I dropped out and then I
started to go part-time to baroque and I
really focused on then learning how to
give facials which was sort of a side
gig off the personal training because my
skin got so bad so one summer instead of
going to the Hamptons where I would be
you know try to I yeah
trapped by a wealthy family who wanted
me to exercise them at whatever time of
a day I don't don't think what you're
thinking actually still don't even know
where you're going but I decided I would
take a course in how to get facials and
so I went to the christine.roney school
of facials which was the only thing
then and learned about how to do facials
and skin you know skin treatments and
waxing and all that kind of stuff then I
after convinced my personal training
clients to let me practice giving them
facials after I would give them a
personal training session so I would
carry a steamer on my back and go up to
Park Avenue and have all the first the
workout equipment right I'm in the
steamer and all of the beauty equipment
and I would run them up and down their
stairs and I do yoga class a bit and
then I would get them a facial amazing
and then I learned how to get better and
better of course at doing facials and
then I got a small studio in the East
River Savings Bank building on Spring
Street in Lafayette and then people
started coming to me and then I
gradually started doing less personal
training and more facials and then it
kind of went from there very organic so
literally the business started by you
scratching your own itch of trying to
solve your own singular problem that's
always it isn't it you know this is a
huge thesis of mine which is why I'm
leaning in and I love that you jumped on
it
yeah like would you tell me that the
five businesses since sorta for this is
a sense have similarities or then it
evolved later on certainly two of them
absolutely have similarities fit flop
which was one of them I had no time to
exercise you have any sense that you
were an entrepreneur
uhm now as a kid well okay I never had a
job working for anybody else okay that's
a good take so what does a kid like
shoveling snow or like trying to make a
buck was that in you yeah babysit I had
maybe three or four part-time jobs when
I was in high school okay
yeah because I had to cuz my dad died
when I was 11 so thanks but it gave me a
gift yeah I understand yeah adversity is
the foundation of success yeah and you
learned that you just got to make it for
yourself nobody's gonna provide what is
right for you
no and my mom did not cry for me not for
a second so there was no don't worry
it'll be fine yeah I don't think I ever
heard that it was let's figure this out
it was me saying to her let's figure
this out I understand yeah so we figured
it out and actually it's really served
me so it's a terrible thing that happens
but you got to turn everything into
understand yeah why is it working for
you instead of to you best mom in the
world and she lost her mom at five yeah
so ty I genuinely believe that a lot of
her greatness yeah
comes from that adversity Jie and the
natural DNA in a million other variables
but understood yes so so
what how did bliss come about from that
singular location well so I had that one
facial treatment room and it got really
busy and people used to have to wait in
the hallway so I got a larger space
where we built out three treatment rooms
and manicures and pedicures and then I
hired a receptionist and we had him real
yeah I became real and it was still
called let's face it and then the
waiting list that we had there was you
know 18 months so people are starting to
actually get angry because if they tried
to rebook an appointment and they didn't
book 18 months in advance facials yeah
people would book i want to x' day night
I want the second Tuesday of every month
and they booked 18 months Oh 18 months
got it the whole schedule was booked 18
months out so you just couldn't get in
so I thought well I've got except my own
knowledge was a completely word-of-mouth
or did the post or the times or did some
did you have a viral moment in the old
media sure yeah we had a lot of we had a
lot of magazine press not much newspaper
at the time when I opened blessed we had
the times yeah but everything else was
kind of vulgar glamour or self what I
really were my clients is that what it
was driving it we had a lot of those yep
yep yeah I understand yeah you know they
need facials too I've heard yeah so how
did it go to bliss so then it was that
it was the 18-month waiting list and
people were starting to get really upset
that we couldn't you know get anybody
else in so people would call and there
was just no way you could get in for any
kind of appointment for every month yeah
so obviously you've got to expand right
and happened to be an empty space in our
building the Leo Castelli Art Gallery
and so he was closing and we took over
and opened Wow it took about six months
to build it was upstairs in the same
building so I could run up and down and
look at the construction and choose
paint colors and all that kind of stuff
which was great and we opened in July of
2006 and it was ten rooms and you named
it bliss I did because I wanted to I
thought what is the greatest feeling
that I can give to my client so that
when they're in here or they're walking
out they just have a moment of you know
what is the very best thing I can
provide because people in New York I
mean still are right so stressed yeah so
fast yeah you just need a minute and
what do you want to make them feel and
then
have that you you have that feeling and
then that moment and then all the hair
on your body stands up it was one of
those moments when that name came to me
that was it and what happened for there
so we opened in July of 2006 there were
10 treatment rooms and it was full so
vote about us again and then it was a
New York Times article and we were you
know from the same problem section in
the same problem just a bigger scale
yeah so then we had to think okay what
are we gonna do now because we still had
to pay off the construction and yet we
had no rooms available so then we were
looking for a space above it below and
we ended up expanding upstairs but it
took a couple of years because we had no
money so it was that you know I never
borrowed I just hoped you just executed
you got it execute anybody can be your
eyes anybody can hope yes anyone can
hope right yeah I gotta execute against
the hope you you prepare yeah yeah so
never east capital no I've never East
Capitol I've stuffed it between my
mattresses and saved it you know yeah
well you gotta be frugal and then what
happened it got so hot that the big
company came along and yeah we had a few
circling around so in 1999 was kind of
this yes time for everybody watching cuz
there's a lot of youngsters yeah 1999 it
was just like it is now you know I make
fun of too much money in the system yeah
there was a lot and it was you know
bliss was there Kate Spade's yeah she
had just started her company crunch yep
had just started remember all of those
things at the same time there was a real
energy creative energy going on there
always is in New York thank God yeah
it's true but then they seem to be Pacus
when new brands come or these brands
stay yeah because Bliss is still very
big today it's great but it doesn't
always have feel great about that
yeah yeah it's cool yeah it means you
really made something that really
resonates and it's timeless you know
what's fun is when it's not your company
you're driving along and now you see a
new location and you just like smile or
think back so go in that's yeah it's got
something that actually keeps it pretty
quickly after yeah you know you had your
first place but as bliss it was only
three years huh yeah we were well three
years in we started to get approached by
a lot of different large conglomerates
um you know for a lot of entrepreneurs
that are going through this right now
were you kind of like I'm never selling
I'm gonna build this monster no okay so
you're not always open to it I would I
never thought about it I never thought
about it but I had lived on a futon with
a small television and a vacuum cleaner
in a one-bedroom apartment in the East
Village for you know a long time by the
way remember how I always talk about how
did you have the money to do things how
did you not borrow money there was your
answer yeah you go to Benny's burritos
once a week if you're lucky one of the
biggest things I get pushback on to get
it from me is cuz I talked about not
pointing the money back into business or
not making as much money yeah and people
don't understand that you could have a
huge business but live like [ __ ]
everybody thinks of business is supposed
to take like so many people take the
money out of the business so they can
live glamorous and I'm like the business
is your life yeah that's gotta be it
right you got a sacrifice that's what
your choice yeah of course but I didn't
know how to do anything else but I'm
sure you remember just to remind some
people like I'm sure there were people
in your life at that point
bliss is hopin it's getting all this
press and then you have like a friend
come over Blake this is where you [ __ ]
live yeah sure
could you love that I don't care yeah
caris I mean it's not you're not doing
it for other people you're doing it for
yourself and I don't care what anybody
thinks about where I live and it was
perfectly fine and one of my friends did
great trompe l'oeil on the inside of my
apartment for a couple of facials we
swapped for a baby yeah I loved it at
the time and you know what I walked to
and from work it was great it was [ __ ]
like if you when I think about where I
lived the seven years I was building the
wine business it was just a [ __ ] bed
yeah you're not there you're not there
you're not there no it's like staying in
really really expensive hotels
I know it's glamorous for Instagram and
stuff but you know what come on you're
barely in there honestly I'm just really
focused on the water pressure and the
Wi-Fi yeah the why it's gotta be today
if the Wi-Fi it clean you don't worry
I'm a little bit dirty that way like I'm
even weird like sometimes like weird
[ __ ] has happened to me like traveling
in hotels like the bed is not as clear
like there's something maybe a weird
hair like nothing skeeves me that
nothing excuse me nothing skis would be
the Huskie nothing scuse me they are but
if the water pressure a shower isn't
good I'm [ __ ] dead okay I need water
pressure and I need Wi-Fi yeah
really when I bothe my apartment at my
home like right now like that like to my
wife it was like that's the only two
things that matter to me I must nothing
else my decent mattress I don't know
I'll probably but I don't really know
what I thought I'm so [ __ ] exhausted
at the end of the day then I'm like
sleep and regardless yeah like yeah yeah
yeah yeah water pressure yeah in the
shower
Wi-Fi earplugs you know what I'm so
[ __ ] on god oh I don't mind
earplugs I've done it like a bugs you
know what I could find some really good
if I'm able to know that for some weird
reason occasionally eight days a year
that I can really sleep in yeah your
plugs when I'm home and I know we can
sleep to noon if I need it that's what
I'll do it because I'm like I'm not
missing this rare opportunity to go like
for fifteen hours of sleep yeah but but
water pressure
why fine okay I keep it basic anyway I
got it
so bliss sells whistles and I hate for a
while makes sense yep because hand it
over I get it and they wanted me to stay
like that when you when you obviously
meet some money in that yeah what if
anything did that mean to you buy a
better place cuz you're ready about an
apartment yeah Brooklyn we brought in
Dumbo when it was just up and coming you
know that really great yeah he drilled
it actually yeah he did really well [ __ ]
if you bought in 2000 or 2001 Dumbo yeah
[ __ ] crazy crushed it he's really
good good for him at the real estate
yeah yeah and he and he actually
convinced me I wanted to buy a small
apartment and you want a bigger he went
bigger he was right and then he when we
moved out of New York he saw that for
you know really yeah where'd you move
from New York we moved to London because
we had open to bliss in London and we
wanted also to be a little bit closer to
his family who's in France so we thought
you know what we've done New York for 18
years he'd been here for probably 25 so
let's try London we had a lot of friends
there we'd opened the new spa there so
it was cool it was nice and we wanted to
have kids and it's quite human there yes
no let's outdoor space yes and so it's
and it's nice to be though yes
and we can come back and forth you know
it's so easy now
just a little macro as we've got Micro
when people ask you because you've had
so much success in your entrepreneurial
career when people ask you like what
stands out what's worked what's your
advice
what are your go-to like if you it's
like a family friend if you were like if
this weekend you went out on morale day
and like somebody you know like a young
person guy or gal comes to me says I
want to be an entrepreneur
what are your go-to like what are your
top things probably to lose one there's
no shortcut it's never a shortcut there
is no way around it you just gotta work
and sacrifice
okay two and three I might forget do you
feel like Dori you'll remember do you
feel go ahead finish okay yeah I
sometime I get it I do the same thing
honestly that's why I let you do it I'm
like I would forget so go okay though if
you choose one thing it means you can't
choose the other right now people don't
seem to get this oh I get it okay so
there's this book called the road less
traveled did you read it
not only [ __ ] it gets a little bit just
at the end but when you get to page 26
or something there's him telling a story
about how he chose to do something and
then didn't have enough time to do
something else and was complaining to
his professor because he chose to do
something when he actually didn't have
to do it and the professor pointed out
to him that this was your choice you can
choose anything you want so if you
choose a you probably can't get B if you
choose B you can't get a choose one and
then don't [ __ ] about it that's kind of
it right you've got to understand
there's a sacrifice with every choice
you want to open a business you may not
have a glamorous pad or a car or be able
to go out all the time you may have no
social life this is your choice but you
don't get it all and don't waste time
complaining
cuz that doesn't get you anywhere either
and it's a big drain it makes you really
boring
I forgot number three number three okay
we had to uh no it'll come to me you
asked me something else
listen I think I think that I couldn't
be a bigger buyer of what you're putting
off I remember I go okay don't sell it
if you're not gonna buy it yourself
right so how many of us have sold
something that actually if it was your
money you would not buy yourself for
that price that item and if you won't
you cannot it's not gonna do well if
it's not good enough
don't do it just wait wait nothing makes
me happier then then legitimately giving
advice I've taken and I think about it
the same way yeah like I agree cuz
you'll the intent of the whole thing is
dead
yeah if deep down you know it's not
something you would buy yeah I couldn't
believe it people always ask me they're
like there's such a good salesman I'm
like cuz I believe so [ __ ] much in
what I'm selling yeah if you like your
stuff if you would buy your stuff if
your house is full of your own stuff
it's good star on dog food yeah you have
to wait expect other people to eat I
believe I believe it yeah it's that
simple yeah we gotta be willing to work
like what what's your take on the
current state of entrepreneurship it's
become so cool this was not as cool as
when you and I were coming up the game I
you know I found it cool cuz that was
just a nice fit for my friend about lit
for you yeah and they just felt like the
only possibility because I would never
really see things the way I mean I did
III think I misspoke earlier in that I
said I never had a job when I was a
teenager I worked in a restaurant I
worked at a gym so I did work for
somebody but I never quite agreed with
the way that they executed and I was 17
and that was killing me that we were not
doing things properly and I was just the
aerobics teacher so it's so much easier
for me and it leaves me so much more at
peace if I can make my own decisions and
then execute you know it's the same
reason you'd never take your money
I suppose so I don't know because I've
never I need the money
it's why you have it yeah well if you do
understand this I feel such a kinship
towards you like I don't want the money
I want the freedom yeah and to do
something beautifully and just know that
it's the right thing and be able to feel
excited about it cuz when stuff is pure
and you feel like you have given it all
and there was no compromise and you
didn't have to fake and it's just right
that you you know when you give it makes
you feel great right oh [ __ ] like you
don't even care about the results you
know what's great but it's still you
know you gotta eat yeah you don't wanna
smile
but yeah but you know what's so
fascinating about giving is so many
people think they give but what they're
actually doing is manipulating yes a lot
of people say to me Gary I give I go no
you don't I go cuz I know you and you
tried to give to me what you were
actually doing was you were trying to
get something from me and you may
pretend you were giving to me to get
what you wanted from it you have to
think really hard to even get through
that but it's actually very simple like
I genuinely believe the reason giving is
so powerful is so few people actually
give without expectation yes that when
you taste it you're it's intoxicating
yeah people always like everyone's so
drawn to you I'm like cuz I'm [ __ ]
giving ya like it's not super
complicated around here like cuz I'm
giving it cost nothing right when it's
your natural framework we are capable
when you have when you're like there's
so many things that go back yep come on
it's practice everything's everything's
everything's pronounced you know a
hundred percent
everything is practiced by the way I'm
watching on Facebook YouTube Instagram
please put your phone number in Andy's
gonna grab some questions but as you can
see I'm enthralled in this conversation
what uh on your current business yeah
beautify yeah I want to talk about that
because the way you it's interesting I
wonder if you've talked about your other
businesses this way I always wonder if
the one as you kind of structured it in
the way you were talking is the one the
one that just happens to be current for
entrepreneurs or is the like I don't
know it was interesting when you said
I'm like oh I wonder how I think about
that yeah why do you think this was the
mother lode the one you know it's when
you can do something and build a
business and this is beauty pie my
latest business which is like a giant
buyers club for people who love luxury
beauty products what's the buyers club
it educators so buyers club is when you
you go in with a group so there's a
large group of people all members of
club who can buy direct from a source
without paying for middleman or
marketing or any retailer markups yeah
and that's my definition of a buyer's
club but they're not reselling it it's
or is it no they're not recently end
users so our members are the end users
of the product and I worked in the
beauty industry for such a long time and
what I realized you know over so many
years of doing
the spot was incredible because you're
putting your hands on somebody and
really changing how they feel yes you
really transfer an energy to them and
that's worth money that service is worth
payment right and for everybody who
worked in this bar it it felt like a
good exchange in a fair exchange in
cosmetics and especially when you get to
more expensive cosmetics or the luxury
types how does that start at what price
point just for listen what's luxury to
some people but what a $50 face cream up
to a 200 dollar up to $300 $400 face
cream generally the cost of goods on
something like that where it's about 8%
and the reason for that is because you
let's do easy math right if you're
selling to a retailer and the retailer
is selling that cream for $100 right 60
of it goes to the retailer so then you
back out everything else the marketing
the free samples the middleman the
celebrity whoever you pick blah blah
blah
8% so a woman who is buying or a man who
is buying $100 cream is getting an $8
cream because of all of this stuff in
the middle that doesn't do anything
better for their face and what I
realized after how is this different
than a direct-to-consumer brand that may
make those obviously all the DTC
explosion yeah how is this buyers club
concept yeah yeah well a were
transparent so we actually show
customers exactly how much it cost to
make the product so you auto flat out
everything here's exactly what the
package cost the formula that goes into
it the packing safety testing etc etc
and then they can buy up to a certain
amount each month of product based on
which membership they chose but we never
value membership as well you see left at
Costco yeah it's like Costco it sounds
like it it's like Costco but people
always say it's not like Costco don't
say it's like Costco like well that's
like Costco in America the people that
are trying to tell you to not say that
extent Costco
no there are people who are ideological
not executing but Costco is amazing
so imagine Costco right filled with
amazing beauty stock goes amazing to you
and I yeah as a business model they're
speaking in very layman's terms of like
don't associate with Costco cuz the
Chris
but it's not I know it's not fair
[ __ ] folks and everybody thousand
dollars yeah yeah and everybody's in
there with the Range Rover so people pay
for membership he paid your limit you're
authentic with what the cost is you know
just a map actually pay that cost of the
product because the membership covers
your margin the membership my god it's
so easy and so it's been yeah but come
on okay now look at it this way so
imagine or any added value or as access
the to buying the product what they're
paying for its access and then they have
limits based on what's going she makes
margin on their products not just you
don't well here's why please I didn't
want to make it a margin game because
that it eliminates the purity of it so
did you consider flat-out showing people
that you were gonna make a six percent
margin on it um in transparency because
that was the other thing that I know
because talking no because I want people
to know exactly how much it costs I do
not want to ever get into this margin
game where there is a motivation to go
back into it because the way cosmetics
work is it's always this I got it
I gotta want a $50 cream oh by the way
it's not just cosmetics it's every
[ __ ] one but cosmetic I started
direct arted empathy wines for the same
reason yeah I suppose I cut out why
stuff that we know now we're making a
margin on it because we don't have the
membership component but I love what
you're doing
not to mention every single person in
here who's listening right now I was
like oh I'd like like anybody here right
who may be not into cosmetics but
there's something else is saying Oh
cupcakes oh yeah oh you know shampoo
like I like that I like knowing exactly
what it cost and the app now what's
interesting is you'll be able to build
on top of the membership if you choose
to over time in terms of well right now
we value your coming in well no I'm not
coming I'm just I'm brainstorming cuz I
can't I can't help because I love it
yeah yeah he's right I can't help it you
have a business where the value to pay
for them what are the membership lay up
letter love 10 20 30 a month and allows
you to buy you know this XYZ right so
I'm paying 120 dollars a year for the
ability to buy things that cost yeah
that you know and then something would
be times car correct and it's up to you
to deliver a product that I like in that
variable what I'm thinking is that's
going to be a very valuable proposition
and that a lot of people gonna be
excited I think so and so what you're
able to do over time though is now you
have millions of people subscribe to the
membership we not actually get them
better prices of course we've done that
already with like a lot of stuff is now
half the price of using your volume yeah
faster and we always just go for the
best well what you can do next gets
really interesting though whether it's
events whether it's like there's apps
you have unlimited access cuz you have
first party data at scale of end
consumer whoever's closest to the
customer wins yeah I think so you can
either so much out of it and they get so
much out of it and a beautiful thing
here is they win let's get a call we win
I love it it's amazing so this started
two years ago yeah we just launched okay
we launched in the UK and then we also
we have a warehouse in the US we are set
up and ready to go yeah yeah just and
starting and did it did it did it click
in did you know right away you how'd it
go
no actually you know what people
couldn't believe that that's what really
cost to me yeah and so they assumed that
the product wasn't as good yeah now
they're learning now they're learning
it's just a little while I guess and
like the pure the pure you know doing
the right thing right it's always gonna
win in the end so sorry
no love you so much Michael for
Minnesota Michael it's Gary Vaynerchuk
hey Gary Michael how are you how are you
I'm extremely extremely well thanks for
calling in and please say hello to Marcy
holy holy [ __ ] hi hello how are ya how's
it going good how are you you have a
question yeah um yeah I'm gonna be a
real fast so I'm 22 years old okay um
I'm from the Philippines four years ago
okay in the United States
finish school and stuff like that but
I'm planning to go into military okay
and I'm contemplating between sales or
go through military to pay for college
and then build the business from there
so are you going to the military so you
don't have college fees yes sir yeah and
right now
my friend my your my parents with that
I'm not gonna pay for my trip totally
and and are you currently in college or
you in high school about you're 23 you
said so with the moving from the
Philippine I do so you've gone to
college already and caught debt and the
way to clean that debt is to go to the
military I'm doing
I didn't one your college I just got
enough college credits to start as a
high rank in the military
but then again what I'm doing right now
I have like three [ __ ] jobs one
full-time into part-time so the two part
times I'm doing brand ambassador so
basically selling [ __ ] like that talking
about the product and you know so right
now I enjoy doing I enjoy doing sales
but let me ask you worried about let me
ask you a question okay you're thinking
about going to the military to pay for
college for the sake of having a college
student for the sake of having a college
degree yeah they're alright just so you
know you're talking with two people here
one who didn't go to college and now I
might I went to Mount Ida College which
is like I might be the reverse like no
question my sixth grade classes in
Edison New Jersey were tough for them
out of college so like you're talking
like I'm worried that you're putting a
college degree on a pedestal and
deciding to go to military to pay for
something that actually won't bring you
any value other than perception it may
or may not it may or may not
yeah I dropped out of college okay and
I'm doing very well why do you want to
go to college let's start with that
basically I mean most of your
insecurities so therefore I can get a
training from the military and then
college but no no I'm seeing it in I'm
so I went to Maricopa is graduation
right okay and there's like at least
five hundred of them graduate at least
30 grand a book and student that yeah
time's up by five hundred that's like
almost 220 million right there I can't
say for [ __ ] 32 grand of college but
what does that have to do with you and
why do you want to go to college like I
said so it's basically just for
securities I have money going in and but
I'm really not so sure what I want to do
in college in the first place bro I'm
telling you right now
this is my biggest you know you're
talking to people who also love building
brands the great brand that America
built and in cahoots with college is
college in America yeah like if you if
you go back and watch this tonight
what watch this cuz this is gonna
although you know watch this 50 times
you have no rationale to you're
literally gonna go to the military to
pay for something and spend three years
there to pay for something that you have
no reason or knowledge to why you want
it other than it's the thing you're
supposed to do yeah I completely agree I
think it's you know if you know what you
want to do in college and it's a path to
lead you to where you absolutely want to
go great but if not just go get a job
right I'm Gary I want to be a sports
agent like your brother and I want to be
that means I have to become a lawyer and
I have to go to law school I'm like ah
that makes sense
but you know in this huge wave of
entrepreneurship or sales or all this
stuff we now live in a world where the
biggest companies in the world no longer
are requiring a college degree you know
you can DM your way into a job these
days I'm just struck like I'm I hate
that kids are going to the military and
kids are taking on huge debt to do
something that they perceive like they
perceive as fun or the right thing to do
or this notion that well I can always
fall back on my college degree what do
you guys do it's just not true not to
fall back to what okay so like I said
right now I'm doing to brand ambassador
your job so I go to Walmart to talk to
people all day [ __ ] day lot so should
I just stick to that develop the skill
and then move on well you should
definitely not do is commit two to three
years of your life to the military to
pay for a piece of paper that you have
no [ __ ] idea what to do with in the
first place your Liberty what you just
said to me as I'm 23 years old and I
plan on graduating college at 26 27 28
29 years old but you have no logic to
why you want that piece of paper
sometimes I think if you just get in
there get a job stay with your job try
and get a different job try different
things out write your
the market you find out what you like
doing and then you might want to go to
college later you or your parents or
your girlfriend or girlfriend's parents
or some TV show you watched eleven years
ago put the idea of college on a
pedestal and you're still acting on it
hmm yeah I agree and the military is a
big risk isn't it
sure is yeah like anything can happen
yep I mean it's just real life I mean
yeah about the thoughts of like where
everybody goes when we say that like
fine like obviously world rulers aren't
popping out every day forget about that
and military by the way I love the
military I'm sure it can bring a lot of
discipline and things of that nature I
love the military I love college
I love entrepreneurship I just love
self-awareness more than all three so
like when when you do Q&A and I can ask
you this question you have no answer yep
yeah I agree this is good this is why
I'm excited like I don't think the
college degree as a back-up plan is as
big of a deal as you think and I think
you need to think about that okay I
think that's a great answer thank you
you are so right thank you all right
brother take care let's get one more
I'll take that one
you know it's interesting and listen you
and I grew up in an era where the degree
did carry more weight I mean like and
I'm thinking forward not backwards I can
make a statement I'm very confident
up.look college is right for some people
it's not right for some people there's a
million things I will say this the brand
of a college degree is not increasing in
our society now it is decreasing the end
supply and demand supply and [ __ ] see
god I love you
[ __ ] we are similar like honestly it's
that basic like I don't think you and I
are some incredibly crazy entrepreneurs
we just understand be very practical
Adam yeah it's Gary Vaynerchuk say hello
hey what's going on
how are you I'm excellent how are you
I'm super well what's your question for
Marcy and I oh well my question is I'm
I'm building my bridge into for my
platform yeah I'm listening don't listen
to the don't listen to the podcast
turn that off we're live here on the
radio you got a delay all right no
worries
oh my god I said radio because that's
what I used to say on support' song
they're like turn it down that's so
funny where your brain does
alright good we're right here what's
your question brother okay my question
is I lost a platform to sell your Tesla
and I want to know if I should accept
outside funding in the point the form of
equity I've got a I've got an equity
company on my ass or borrow the money
from like from someone or just keep
struggling you and using my sales money
and and to build my version - well I
think I'd keep struggling and use your
sales money to build your version - me -
yeah trance state independent as long as
you possibly can and borrowing from a
bank high net worth individual and
definitely taking money from a venture
capitalist is not staying independent
now look you've got two people here who
have never taken funding for their
businesses the only time I've ever had
any cash infusion in my business was
when AJ and I decided to sell peace to
Steve Ross but we took every dollar off
the table not one of those dollars was
used to operate so I don't I don't like
using money to operate a business
because I think it creates bad behavior
yeah yeah it doesn't you spent so
different right and it doesn't take a
hero to lose money every month no and
everybody's losing money every month
you're preaching no no just suffer as
long as you can as long as other people
tell you like you need the capital
because you only have a window you know
I don't know um it all depends like if
you're building a business that has a
window you're building something
vulnerable to begin with yep yeah
there's no shelf lighter than that yep
yeah but but but the money is so so
alluring yeah that's why [ __ ] people
lose a lot of things are alluring doing
cocaine to hook up with chicks is
alluring yeah that's not right all right
you know the longer that you operate I
think the longer you operate on your own
money right the more you learn how to be
incredibly responsible with it and be
strategic with it and the sooner that
you have too much money the more
wasteful you get with it and you don't
think it's hard I think what's gonna
bring you you think hard
what's alluring about them
bro break it down for me how'd you keep
me from your first time it yeah from
your perspective well the only thing
about the money as soon as I get it I
can I can I can be more more comfortable
I'm I've been living I've been
struggling for life a year and I finally
got the platform going I got sales
coming in right
it's not easy a year hey you gotta yo
you got a buck up I said I'll go for ten
years right one year is that you are
spoiled brother yo kings playing brother
you're giving up your business a piece
of your business for a year think in
another can you suffer for another year
suffer well might be three three times
as far ahead
no I'm just used to living on very
little I got used to living ever hungry
brother that's the best are you seed
bagels pretty much every day all day I
don't want to eat food ever again honey
I wanna I want to do nothing I want to
like never leave this room like guys
like bro that's if you've gotten used to
it you're about to [ __ ] up your [ __ ] if
you're used to it is a great place to be
it got pretty skinny too yo you really
can't eat at all she can like she's got
a phone what no no I can I can eat tell
me here howdy here help me here
what do you say bone broth hypno pendejo
on a serious note like without like
humor stuff cuz I really want to help
you here like ya is like do you want to
take the money do you not want to take
the money like what's the punchline here
I I kind of want I do want to take the
money but at the same point I'm like it
I built this from zero to two you know a
few grand a month now what why why just
why bother taking the money you know why
why why it's like I'm being pimped out
yeah I agree I agree you're so early in
the process a year is nothing yeah like
like you haven't even started do you
believe in the business long term yes
yes I definitely believe I'm just a my
sales are going up everyday is the end
every month is anybody pressuring you to
take them
that's not you mother father siblings
spouse no no I don't know no pressure I
mean I know one's pressure I'm no
external pressure good yeah yeah you
listen I think the longer you can stay
independent the more likely you're
building something meaningful and the
value is exponential the longer you can
hold on to it without getting any
investors in okay good luck bro thank
you brother
yeah I mean look I think we're built
from similar Clausen listen there's a
lot of business that are capital
intensive things that nature but I think
what I'm overreacting to these days is
everybody thinks the only way you can
succeed is by raising capital Yeah right
like that was they I didn't even hear of
that in my until my early 20s everything
was maybe you could get a bank loan and
maybe not but most likely you got to
figure it out and sign flags yeah it
wasn't I'm just gonna go out there and
try and scale something and waste a lot
of money I was wrapping it up laying
what out what else have we not covered
in these couple like last couple minutes
anything you want to talk about Oh see
if we've talked about Beauty pie we have
um let's see we've talked about there be
no shortcuts yes
ah please the question of the day yes
that will come up but we're not there
are you asking it or I'm asking it I do
I have to come up with the question of
the day that is correct oh I thought I
had the answer of the day because that
would be the question you think about a
question of the day is about what is the
meaning of life right you know what's
funny it's either super in the clouds
yeah or you use the audience as a focus
group and you can ask a very simple kind
of tactical question that may give you a
huge insight into something I love
asking questions for answers because
it's insight yeah of course you know
it's insight what do you wait what do I
think of meaning like this yeah that's
that's true you know what's so funny you
said it earlier quietly while somebody
was talking I think one of the things is
we're getting to know each other that we
completely connect on is utter
practicality hmm the meaning of life is
like the least practical thing I could
ever think of
oh but actually it's quite practical mmm
I think having a North Star is practical
okay which is different to me than the
macro but it's all how we interpret yeah
here's my thing to meet the the ambition
of my life and the wish that I would
have on everybody besides
because if you're not healthy it's game
over is genuinely enjoying the process
evolution however you want to call it
yeah I just love the fact that I wake up
every morning and I love it which is why
I like the booing which is like why I
love the struggles to me the trophies
are so not interesting now they're just
not no they're not just don't mean
anything they only mean something if
you're insecure and you want to show
somebody the trophy yeah I mean it you
said something earlier like so
authentically and it was so pure which
was like I don't give a [ __ ] what my
friends thought about my apartment think
you said that no you said oh did I and
and I and bad into it scared no no you
might have not said [ __ ] but I
definitely approve the way I think you
said or whatever you said that's the
[ __ ] game yeah that's the question
what do you admire out there these days
cuz you know the more I'm sitting with
you like I'm like oh this is one
thoughtful lady like what it what is
what if I said to you HOT take give me
three or four things you admire you
could say anything country's individuals
brands business model like just straight
up right now what's gotten your
attention you're like oh that's and you
may not even have a fully thought
through thing like oh I want to explore
that a little bit like what's got your
attention in the world outside of your
four walls is it Robert Smith Robert
Smith okay I admire that because just
the idea of let's make it easy for some
other people and let's hope that they
then take that energy and make it easy
for the next people and just being able
to lift someone up like that so funny
you said that EXO caught my attention
too okay what else
what's a product that you love right now
that it's nothing to do with your world
product or your attention sure you know
what I'm so in the middle of my world I
know really I know it's because I
actually don't look so much at product I
get it anything used that you love what
do I use it I'm Ariel a drink shampoo
what yeah my airports but you know what
I love them this for me you know this is
like my finger okay but wait we know
that we all have been in peace well
we've got like literally I asked this
question when I do dinners and you had
my answer for the last year and a half
has been this okay
really that's [ __ ] crazy you've heard
that in some of them wait wait didn't
you eat the whole argument against
airpot cancer live ahead no it was more
about how they're they they the
batteries don't recharge right and they
only last for X amount of time Tim
Cook's done well under his watch there's
so much they changed your life a minute
I bought them for everybody in the
office for Christmas because they're so
good
smart I mean really you feel free what
you can't communicate what else
what do you couldn't soup content watch
listen to anything I do I wonder Ted Ted
yeah I listen up podcasts like how I
built this Freakonomics I listened to
yours cuz I had to prepare for this and
it was good thank you yeah and you know
look this tons of podcasts that I listen
to because there's just so much enjoyed
information I loved Ray Dalio
he's amazing okay that's it write that
if you're gonna be an entrepreneur go
listen or read that book yeah like at
least once a year makes a lot of threats
just to remind yourself what's really
important and what the truth is I'm
really really really really looking
forward to getting to know you better
likewise I really really like where your
head's at question of the day
oh it's gonna be what was the meaning of
life and then that's it thank you so
much for being on the show yes super
enjoyed it you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them
what about the tequila we never got to
it no on this episode
she's so damn interesting we never even
drink the tequila we could now I gotta
get the hell out of here thank you